allez allez allez allez allez au boulot
là au boulot la vieille [ __ ] le boulot
c'est ma mère monsieur n'a pas fait un
client je suis seul frein puisses tu es
vraiment nul
si vous aimez talent et si vous aimez
les grosses budget une affaire pour vous
regardez c'est ma mère venez venez sur
ma mère allait pas cher du tout non mais
c'est lola sepa pasqua est ce que tu es
là souvent moment évidemment monsieur
alors pour passer un sapin
moi 5,18 à moins 5 j'ai un rendez-vous
immédiatement plus loin la princesse est
vachement important
j'accuse juillet à la corde et vous fera
passer après par là je vous offre les
pin's à l'an passé
je leur parle théoriquement ok ça vous
dirait de lui grimper dessus pour 50
francs ok il est d'accord ils ont
repassé tout à l'heure et toi qui aime
bien les vieilles jeu ma mère tu quand
même mieux ses 50 francs c'est normal
qu'il y ait des députés dans le quartier
comme ça des [ __ ] madame d'aidé paris
pp était député
je dis ma soeur est à pigalle ça ça
marche bien
mon père est rue sainte anne mais s'est
fait casser le croupion deux fois ce
matin on a fait un petit peu de chiffres
je sais pas s'il ya autant de défis
maintenant il ya plus de travestis
maintenant je vois mon nom que la caisse
quitter tom pognon c'est étonnant arrêts
étonnant et puis on m'a retiré du coeur
à l'ouvragé
il peut faire 80 militaires l'at il est
vraiment laid comme edith vous toujours
que tant qu'on a la santé
enfin c'est 80 militaires 1 1 c'est pas
rien dégrader et tout voilà oui madame
blue est pas resté là non plus fait pas
le trottoir ah non non s'il veut pas les
voir depuis sur le trottoir on est
d'accord si je m'excuse moi j'invite à
pendant pas une [ __ ] cependant à temps
pour moi alors je vous dis ça j'ai déjà
à cause de la coiffure oui oui voilà non
parce que je m'attendais c'est ma mère l
a pas fait un client depuis quatre ans
alors une [ __ ] qui ne fait pas de
clients en bureau sidéré que ce n'est
pas une [ __ ] voulez que je vous dise qui
je suis monsieur oui c'est doublement
est bien mais ce que je suis la tâche et
du huawei oui monsieur de cet [ __ ]
d'avoir la gentillesse la demande
merci monsieur bonne bourre tenez le pis
je vous donne les pin's vous allez
gagner le pin's
ah les mamans comme en 40 et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux